[Music]
I'm here with reaction oh ho love
breaking news tonight Trump Organization
executive vice president Eric Trump can
I read you something and it's great to
see by the waying congratulations on the
big announcement number two is on the
way and sorry Shawn or excited we
haven't announced it but we're excited
so I think we're zeroed out and guess
what I don't reveal sources like other
people I know that's right you know that
we have a financial optimism 18-year
high 56 percent of Americans their
current financial situations that
cologne are good the highest since 2001
69 percent said they what they expect to
be better off financially in a year the
highest in 16 years Europe is at 0.3
percent growth the last two quarters and
even during a government shutdown your
dad got us three point two percent Obama
couldn't get that in a year in his
entire presidency and hayah stock
markets of all time and best consumer
confidence of all time and lowest
unemployment of all time and you know
lowest joblessness claims of all time I
may I can go on and on and on but we
have the hottest economy in the world
there's no question about it my father
is doing everything he said he would do
which is really put jet fuel on this
economy and he's done it and we are the
envy of the entire world and you know
it's amazing when you look at kind of a
charade that you've been seeing over the
last couple days it's so sad because we
were doing so well and all the Democrats
want to do is distract from that point
all his successes everything he said he
was going to achieve for this country
all they want to do is distract
everybody else from that and it's
actually hugely detrimental to our
country you know Eric I I know when you
have time you have a young young son
who's a great kid when you have time I
know you watch the show I know you know
the issues we've been covering that have
been separate apart and unique from the
rest of the media there are a few of us
you know Laura Tucker they've been great
Fox and Friends have been great not many
others though Russian mark on the radio
and fantastic and it's over the attorney
it's finished anything from here on in
his noise but they want every
else is now go now it's just really
beginning it really is you know it's
intermission and now the second half
begins well you know what Shawn they
won't let it go they were so wrong at
the election right so then it was well
he colluded with Russia and then all of
a sudden that got debunked well there's
obstruction and then that got debunked
well let's subpoena everybody in the
Trump orbit and let subpoena his family
and then let's subpoena his lawyers
unless subpoena his banks and let's
subpoena his accountants and you know
let's just throw a net out into the
middle of the river and hope we catch
something because the narrative once
again totally failed and Trump was right
he was wiretapped at the very beginning
and he was spied on in the deep state
does exist everything that you say every
single night was absolutely true you
know and so now they're grasping at
straws are trying again and and this is
what you get out of these people they
don't want to work for the American
people they don't want to do their jobs
in Congress and I say this as a civilian
people are sick and tired of this
nonsense they want their legislators to
actually work and do their jobs and
that's why you see that you know the
approval rating of Congress it's
terrible because these people are
incompetent III think you you and we saw
this on election night I remember I
called your dad and I said somebody's
drawing straws right now and we're gonna
bring you really bad news because I saw
the eggs of polls pretty early and you
know it's interesting but now they want
okay let's do a fishing expedition
let's get inside tax records let's let's
just let's empower the IRS to bludgeon a
political opponent let's go fishing in
and get his bank records if your father
cured cancer and gave every American
five million dollars and adopted their
agenda I'm still convinced they'd be
obsessed with raging this psychotic
hatred towards him you know what but but
Shawn it tells you that they're failing
as a party if you think about it right
this is what they're focused on they
don't have any leaders out there I mean
these candidates all look very weak to
me I welcome running against quite
frankly any of them and helping my
father and every way we can but you know
they're failing Shawn they don't have a
message you don't have proper leadership
and I'm telling you he's gonna win this
thing again he's gonna win this thing in
2020 because they're just
credibly deranged and by the way we're
energy dependent independent for the
first time in 75 years so many other
great stores by the way you want to beat
the hostile regime of Russia you want to
bring Putin to his knees keep producing
energy it's over for them he's doing
that better than any person in the world
there you go their turn anyway Congrats
on the great news I'm not giving away
the state secret do not do that deal
alright Cletus see you Sean